ils ont gardé le bon tempo et le
chaloupé des reins mais désormais dans
leur bacata et kizomba le collé-serré
essentiel dans ces danses est proscrit
la faute à ce satané virus coville qui a
éloigné il ya des couples en diable et
forcément ça danse - caliente
ce serait mentir ne pas reconnaître que
le contact avec le partenaire et il est
il est manquant un ça va ce moment là
mais on fait l'impasse c'est pas mal de
pouvoir faire ça et a pris par la suite
j'espère que le coc vite va s'en aller
et on pourra danser vraiment là qu'ils
ont mode comme ils le font danser la
kizomba sans connexion avec son
partenaire s'enlève pas mal de
sensualité mais dans le contexte
sanitaire actuelle chacun s'adapte à
danser sans corps gras
les frais l'ascension kizomba les mieux
collé collé mais la date mais la balle
est dans mon cas et voilà prend plaisir
nous avons élevé dé galles une cohésion
sociale il veut dire que ben qu'on a
fait une jeûne et travail 1e roux trouve
à nous on discutait apono pratiquer la
danse voilà ça devrait être bon c'est
brad
on se lâche
on sent bien en juillet il est vrai
qu'en ces temps moroses se lâcher sur de
la kizomba de la pac atteint ou encore
de la zumba
sacha ses tracas il a besoin de ça parce
que voilà le confie déjà les promos nous
la tête et puis ben là c'est tellement
moins de libération de tout le monde me
pense moi spécialement l'hiver doute me
dégage toute passion bachata quand tu
nous tiens même en dés collés serrés ça
continue à envoyer de la sensualité car
ici pour tous jacques attali lombard est
une obsession
[Musique]